now President Trump vowed we were going
to finally win the war against Isis
under his watch I would bomb the data of
him this is an evil sadistic monsters
enemy and we must keep these killers out
of our country we're gonna knock out
Isis so violently and so fast
Isis is being dealt one brutal defeat
and as his first year in office closes
out there's extremely positive evidence
we may be getting closer than ever
Isis has lost now 98% of its territory
in Iraq and Syria according to Ryan
Dillon he's the chief spokesman for
operation inherent resolve hello there
are still major hurdles to conquer
against the terror network in Syria but
this is very encouraging news going into
the new year so my question for you
obviously you know Marie that you are
going to get this first you could feel
you could feel the Mojo so look to ask
the Trump White House what they would
say is and they do say that the Obama
administration wasn't tough enough
didn't take enough steps we hear a lot
of complaints about the rules of
engagement and the approach how much of
that was a strategic choice and how much
of that was an error in judgment well
and some of that is just politics right
so the strategy that has led to a
virtual defeat of Isis in the Caliphate
in Syria in Iraq is largely a strategy
that was laid out during the Obama
administration by military commanders
now President Trump has loosened the
rules of engagement he has allowed the
military to use more bombs for example
and so I think that has helped but for
me the bigger question is what is the
strategy going forward there's tens of
thousands of Isis fighters who once they
lose this territory in Syria in Iraq are
going to go back to Europe they're gonna
go online they're gonna radicalize
people like we've seen try to commit
terrorist attacks here in the US so in
terms of the fight against Isis this is
a
good step but the fight is going to
continue in a different and almost more
dangerous way in Katy I want I do want
to talk more about the online threat the
threat here domestically all of that
razzmatazz but there's also the question
about what happens in Syria next right
and not and one of the reasons by the
way to give the previous administration
some credit where it's due
part of the ghost slow was who's going
to govern Syria and who's going to
govern these fallen places I wouldn't
argue that the ISIS strategy has been
completely about Syria it's actually
been more about getting back that
territory in Iraq and so the
administration has done that through as
you mentioned the rules of engagement
which were severely downplayed during
the Obama administration it was not
reported that 80% of the casualties in
places like Afghanistan in Iraq happened
under Obama's watch as a result of these
rules of engagement second-guessing the
commanders on the ground and you can
give credit to President Obama for the
strategy in the last year of his term
but that was the military commanders but
you have to give credit to President
Trump for actually listening to them and
getting the job done and the thing
that's interesting too going forward as
we look at the Global War on Terror this
is a victory now but this is not
something that has been completely
solved and we're attacking terrorists in
places like Somalia we just learned that
the number of bombings since Donald
Trump took office have doubled in
Somalia in partnership with the the
government they're the one that that's
right such as it is so this is going to
be something we continue to fight
because of the nature of the threat that
we face but it's a huge victory not only
just for getting rid of Isis but also
for the military to feel like they can
finally do their job again Kennedy are
we going to have troops in Iraq and
Syria forever I feel like we are
unfortunately and Afghanistan as well
and that's why whenever we have good
news like the caliphate is 98 percent
contained
you always have to wonder what's the
mission creep what's the next step what
is the ultimate goal of the United
States and of course there are those who
make the case that there are US interest
that have to be secured in those places
and I think that argument gets flimsier
in flimsier and the president said as
much when he was campaigning obviously
the realities of governing are quite
different but the success of containing
Isis is something that has to be
satisfying for him but Katie is
absolutely right you know we can't hang
mission accomplished
banners because this this can go in so
many different directions Syria has
already devolved into civil war and
we've seen places like Yemen and Libya
in an absolute shambles and you know I
hope that the president continues to
indulge his non-interventionist streak
and he has people around him who
understand the cost of human life and
and the amount of money that we have
spent overseas the president has said
that himself in regards to
infrastructure spending and saying hey
why are we spending seven trillion
dollars in the overseas wars when we
should essentially be spending that here
in this country making our bridges and
roads in better - nation-building here
at home I believe is the preferred
phrase of the last two presidents Tom I
like the generals you like to junior pro
generals you know some when he would say
I'm gonna Bob you know III stand with
the men and women in uniform one of the
big advantages of this is that it denies
Isis and the people who now call
themselves Isis a recruiting tool
because when the myth of the caliphate
was alive right they could say we are
building our own nation in the desert we
are going to make this pure thing and
the Calif will be restored and
da-da-da-da-da the physical defeat of it
does deny them a recruiting point but to
everybody's point this is really
metastasized online this is really every
yes although winning is that's why
winning is important I mean Trump is all
about winning and it's true as regards
Isis the more wins you rack up the
better you know and it's it's down now
we want to keep snuffing it out and
count up those victories but I think
this is an area where we do have
bipartisanship I mean everybody hates
Isis so we're kind of all together on
that I think people you know here I gave
President Obama credit when he had
success in that area I also think it was
great when he went back on his word and
he kept Guantanamo Bay like I was glad
he broke that promise I think when it
gets down to it a lot of times that you
know he ran against he said I'm gonna
close Guantanamo gonna change our
foreign policy but then when he got in
there the foreign policy against Isis
wasn't that dramatically changed under
President Obama I think when these
presidents get in there they do take the
advice of the generals and so I think
it's one area where there's a lot of
bipartisanship
even though she disagrees no identity
with President Obama because there were
from Bob gates two people in the
Pentagon you know any time they left the
administration they talked about how
difficult it was because they would lay
out plans for defeating Isis and
President Obama had his own ideas for
how he won't get what wasn't there when
Isis really became a threat I think Bob
Gates had other issues with the
administration the problem that on gates
issues with the administration were
echoed by the problem that energy of the
military was very high open but actually
I think you wouldn't the president the
problem President Obama was trying to
come up against is to the United States
military every problem looks like a nail
and every bomb looks like a hammer and
so there have to be other tools in the
American toolbox but there has to be
other tools to go after threats and I
think he ran on that's right he's
droning William ran on ending the war in
Iraq he ran on getting sprayed and I
stand by the way I'm not saying those
early policy decisions although I happen
to agree with them we were coming out of
the we are still in the longest war in
America's history in Afghanistan yeah
and we have no end in sight to when
these men and women are coming home
President Obama had eight years to end
that war and and he didn't and and I'm
not saying that was okay my point is we
have to look at American power not just
as bombs but as diplomacy as our
economic power as a great deal that did
not work very well when it came to to
Isis the bombing and question to ask
what becomes a Bashar al-assad what
becomes of Syria it's it's it's great to
have Isis it's great to have the people
that as tom points out everyone in the
world universally hates these guys these
guys are the New York Yankees of being
hated about Isis actually joining the
ranks of the Iraqi government in places
where is not stable so there's always
another problem that we're going to have
to see and won't require military action
diplomacy and worked over the past year
is taking out terrorist bombing more and
taking off the rules of engagement but
in terms of how we move forward you
talked about these guys going to Europe
they want the one
laughs - haven't been killed that comes
down to domestic policy that is one
foreign policy whether it's in Europe or
the United States turns into domestic
Pauline how policy and how we deal with
our borders how we deal with vetting of
refugees and on restrain the background
and online radicalization in these areas
that have not assimilated that is one
area where I absolutely agree with Marie
and that is I think we have to be more
mindful than ever of you know what I
refer to as a digital caliphate right
people who have scattered at the forty
five thousand fighters who were fighting
with Isis those people who are now I
mean they're down to a thousand that
means you've got 44,000 yeah and they
have gone to places in Western Europe
and and they are here in the United
States and they are radicalizing in ways
that we have seen here in New York City
with new terror attacks this year or you
don't even have to travel there anymore
it used to be you could truck you could
track someone's travel and it was a red
flag you don't even have to you can go
online um or we do we end up with regime
change are we gonna end up orchestrating
regime change in Syria do you think well
I don't there's another example of you
know say the president's get flexible
when they get into office real flexible
president he changed his view on Syria
remember he came in and he says we're
not gonna you know what do I care yeah
yeah and then he we see how long did it
take him to start bombing Syria so he he
changed presidents change when they get
in here that's why you got a trust job
but not that's why the usual politics do
we end up confronting Russia and we end
up taking out Assad or where does he
stay well maybe if we can get this
investigation to come to a close then we
get offers Muller a deal let me off the
hook I'll take out Assad do you think if
you listen to the left we're not
fighting against Russia we're fighting
with Russia so we're a puppet of you
know the the Soviet regime and we do
whatever Putin proxy were going on and
this is all about the Iranians so not
just about Bashar al-assad it's about
the Iranians being now the focus of this
administration stays I don't know I'm
not gonna predict that but I do know
that the administration is very focused
on Iran and making sure that they don't
creep in more than somebody once said
that Bashar al Assad's days were
numbered that was technical
every one number aren't they yes last
word that the problem has always been if
Assad is not there what fills that void
right that's always been a problem in
Libya and look at the other yeah and
it's gonna be Giancarlo Stanton